d'entrée de jeu justin trudeau a défendu
son bilan en environnement on a beaucoup
fait sur 4 ha en matière de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre le canada est
encore loin des objectifs de l'accord de
paris qui vise une baisse de 30% d'ici
pour l'instant les émissions n'ont
baissé que de 2 %
les autres partis vous disent qu'ils
vont atteindre les cibles de l'entente
de paris mais ils ne pourront pas les
atteindre puisqu'il faut imposer une
taxe sur le carbone de 300 dollars la
tonne pour ce faire et ils ne le font
pas c'est faux selon l'analyse du
directeur parlementaire du budget la
taxe carbone au canada devra augmenter à
102 dollars la tonne de co2 d'ici 2030
pour atteindre les cibles de paris
maxime bernier évoque un prix de 300
dollars la tonne qui serait nécessaire
si et seulement si aucune autre mesure
n'avait été mis en place à compter la
lutte jusqu'à la augmenter les impôts
pour 80 % des familles de la classe
moyenne c'est inexact
les libéraux ont bien aboli certains
crédits dépôts dédiée aux familles mais
le chef conservateur ne tient pas compte
du fait que le gouvernement trudeau a
créé la location canadienne pour enfants
avec ces mesures une famille ayant un
revenu annuel de 110 mille dollars
obtient deux mille dollars de plus à la
fin de l'année dans la dernière année
ce qu'est monsieur trudeau a fait
dépenser beaucoup de dollars 14
milliards de dollars pour les plus
riches entreprises pour qu'elles
puissent acheter des avions d'éléments
dans l'économie de l'automne la mesure
fiscale de 14 milliards de dollars dont
parle le chef du npd vise plutôt à
favoriser l'investissement des
entreprises du matériel de production
d'énergie propre
on est encore en train de bataille nos
cibles d'éliminer les subventions à
l'industrie pétrolière 1 jusqu'en 2025
cette déclaration mérite une précision
ce ne sont pas toutes les subventions
aux pétrolières canada s'est engagé à
éliminer d'ici 2025 et les subventions
jugées inefficaces
de plus le vérificateur général du
canada a conclu que le ministère des
finances n'était même pas capable de
dire combien de mesures fiscales visait
les combustibles fossiles et si elle
était vraiment efficace ici vincent
maisonneuve rens au canada montréal